from child star to tabloid headline
maker let's take a look at what Amanda
bind has been up to since her Heyday
Amanda bind kicked off her professional
career acting in commercials when she
was just 7 years old 3 years later in
1996 she joined the cast of Nickelodean
sketch comedy series All That Bind
quickly became a standout among fans
which led to receiving her own spin-off
series The Amanda Show Shall We
Begin over the course of its three
seasons bindes earned a fair share of
critical praise including four Kids
Choice Awards for favorite television
actress after the show wrapped up in
2002 bines began her film career
starring opposite fellow child star
Frankie munes in Big Fat Liar followed
by waterg once in 2003 while making and
promoting those films bindes was also a
lead on what I like about you alongside
Jenny GTH the show ran for 4 years
before ending in 2006 however it won a
number of Team Choice Awards the actor
closed out the 2000s with a starring
role in the film hairspray and began the
2010s in EA in June 2010 shortly before
the release of EA bindes took to X
formerly known as Twitter to announce
her retirement from acting she cited a
loss of love for the craft as a reason
for her early exit from the spotlight a
month later bind reversed her decision
again using X for her announcement
before deleting her account she
reactivated it later on on April 6th
2012 news broke that Amanda bind had
been arrested for driving Under the
Influence that story was followed by
another on April 10th claiming bind was
involved in a hit and run accident then
bindes was charged with a second hit and
run in August of 2012 as well as driving
with a suspended license that September
in mid 2013 bindes was arrested again
this time in New York on charges of
reckless endangerment and marijuana
possession 2 months later bindes was
placed on psychiatric hold after
starting a fire in the driveway of a
neighbor's home also in 2013 she feuded
with Courtney Love Paris Hilton and
Jenny McCarthy on X in 2014 she used the
platform to publicly accuse her father
of physical emotional and sexual assault
she would later recant those claims
claiming a microchip implanted in her
brain caused her to make these serious
accusations vinds closed out the Year by
announcing she had been diagnosed with
bipolar disorder and manic depression
sharing a reason for her headline making
Behavior she has continued to seek out
treatment for her mental Health even
voluntarily checking herself into a
psychiatric hospital in
2023 Amanda bind remained relatively
quiet for several years after the
chaotic period of 2012 to 2014 she
eventually sat down for an interview
with paper in 2018 drawing W she
apologized for her past Behavior she
also shared that she had been sober for
4 years as she began her road to
recovery bind enrolled in the Fashion
Institute of Design and Merchandising
she earned her associates degree in 2019
before entering a another program at the
school she would eventually take to
Instagram to pitch her dream of making a
clothing line to her followers in her
post she said I'm really looking forward
to starting my clothing line and I'm
hoping that in the near future it will
be out online in her paper interview
bindes expressed an interest in
returning to acting one day however in
2019 she briefly returned to rehab after
an apparent relapse after that the
former actor became active on Instagram
there bind revealed a heart tattoo on
her face a seum piercing to m she
likewise announced her engagement to
Paul Michael however they have separated
since then the couple also shared news
of a pregnancy though her lawyer
announced 2 months later that the actor
was not pregnant in April 2021 binder's
lawyer also spoke with people ahead of
her 35th birthday telling the magazine
that she was doing well living by the
beach while attending school and
partaking in meditation and cycling
classes okay find your
Senter good that's it
in March 2022 a judge ruled a
conservator ship Amanda Bin's mother Lyn
Oran had maintained for the prior 9
years was no longer necessary initially
organ and binder's father Rick bines had
arranged for this conservator ship after
the notorious driveway fire incident in
2013 Amanda Bin's lawyer praised her
parents for the support they provided
her during those 9 years however their
intent was always to end the arrangement
once Bine seemed capable of taking care
of herself which they determined was
feasible in 2022
unfortunately the end of this
conservatorship didn't exactly Kickstart
the Hollywood comeback that many may
have
anticipated like with any popular actor
who hasn't been on the big screen in a
while fans have speculated on a return
to acting for Amanda bind her last major
role was in the emerstone comedy easa
back in 2010 and since then she has not
appeared in any films or television
roles at all many are eagerly waiting
for bindes to have an onscreen comeback
since her acting and comedic Talent made
her a standout back in a Heyday so any
news about her return has been met with
excitement from fans one big rumor going
around was that Amanda bindes would
participate in the all that reunion that
was said to happen between March 2023 at
an event called '90s con Bine spoke to
people at the time to discuss how
excited she was for the opportunity by
saying I'm really excited to reunite
with my castmates and meet the fans at
'90s con sadly this did not end up
coming to fruition since she had to
cancel her convention appearance so the
all that reunion continued without her
speaking about by to Entertainment
Tonight her former all that co-star Kell
Mitchell said it's awesome to see she's
doing better which is great we're just
continuing to pray for her on her
journey and it's answered prayers that
she's doing a lot better while bines
hasn't made her return to acting just
yet there's always a chance she could
return at some point if you or someone
you know needs help with mental health
please contact the crisis text line by
texting home to
741741 call the National Alliance of
mental illness helpline that's 1 1800
950 Nami
6264 or visit the National Institute of
Mental Health
Website